how's it going everyone it's Warren and
if you love Marvel and the MCU today's
video is for you as if there wasn't
already enough hype around Marvel right
now with phase four and phase five
coming up a bunch of different leaks
happening almost every day now plus the
Disney Plus shows coming up it has now
been confirmed that Marvel is going to
continue making shows with ABC now for
those of you who are not familiar ABC is
where you would watch Marvel's agents of
shield now unfortunately this year 2020
is going to be the last year that we see
Marvel's agents of shield as this is the
final season in the last episodes
however ABC is not done with this
superhero game and they plan on making
more shows with Marvel so if you're new
be sure to subscribe when notifications
turned on to stay up-to-date on the MCU
and stick around to the end to hear
about my xbox one and ps4 giveaway so
right now the Television Critics
Association or TCA press tour is
happening and with the press tour
happening we got an update of what to
expect from Marvel TV series on ABC as
ABC Entertainment president Kari Burke
has announced that she's excited to work
alongside Marvel Studios president and
chief creative officer now Kevin Feige
in bringing characters from the comic
brand's ever-expanding influence to the
ABC network now many people thought that
we were no longer going to get TV shows
like Marvel's agents of shield or agent
Carter however ABC entertainments
president Kari Burke has confirmed that
they are going to continue working with
Marvel Studios and making shows the
other day on the press tour she said we
love our partners at Marvel and we're
sad to see Marvel's agents of shield go
it's been a big part of our history
we're looking forward to working with
Kevin Feige and we're at the very
beginning of conversations with him now
about what a Marvel and ABC show might
look like right now Marvel's focus has
been on Disney Plus as it should be so
straight from the mouth of ABC
entertainments president confirms that
ABC and Marvel are in early talks of
developing a new show and this is great
news because obviously if you're here
watching this video you're a Marvel fan
and of course we can't get enough Marvel
and the great news is that if any Marvel
TV show gets produced anywhere it has to
be under the direction of Kevin Feige we
all know Kevin Feige he's the president
of Marvel Studios and he's responsible
for the infinity saga and the creation
of the MCU obviously there's a huge team
that's involved so credit to all the
as well but now Kevin Feige has been
announced chief creative officer of
Marvel Entertainment that means he's in
charge of all comics of all TV shows and
of course all movies so if you happen to
not be a fan of the old TV shows like
Marvel's agents of shield agent Carter
that offenders well they're all under
new direction now under direction of
Kevin Feige
so now the question is if ABC and Marvel
are going to be making a show together
what could this show be well there is a
little bit of evidence about this new
ABC and Marvel show being about the a
force now for those of you who may not
know the a force was Marvel's first
all-female Avengers team members include
Captain Marvel she-hulk miss Marvel The
Scarlet Witch and many many more
now the reason that there's evidence for
this is because ABC was previously
developing a series that focused on a
Marvel female superhero and although we
only got a few details about the show
Burt confirmed last August that the
central character of the series would
have been something brand new mostly
however according to a report from
deadlines these plans have stalled but
could ABC be picking this back up again
focusing on a team and not just a single
Marvel female superhero at the end of
Avengers endgame it certainly did seem
like they were setting up the a force
for future MCU films or shows but
unfortunately right now we're not really
sure if this new show would connect to
the MCU agents of shield was said to
connect to the MCU however the events
that happened in agents of shield were
never mentioned and never affected
anything that happened in the MCU but
the events and the movies affected what
happened in the show so it remains to be
seen what this new show or shows could
be with ABC and Marvel Studios but let
me know what show you would like to see
would you like to see an A for show or
would you like to see something else be
produced let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and of course
don't forget to subscribe but
notifications turned on I like the video
and leave a comment down below to enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 the winner gets to choose
and I'm picking a winner at five hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers don't
forget to follow me on Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof